ende april 2009 10
eine mutter wir nennen sie miriam
severing ist auf dem weg zur
polizeiwache in saarbrücken es geht um
eine anzeige wegen einer bagatelle
angelegenheit
dazu muss sie ihre persönlichen daten
angeben auch die ihres sohnes der
besuchen der polizeistation wird ihr
leben dramatisch verändern
drei jahre zuvor wird in diesem dorf der
assistenzarzt matthias es tot im
schlafzimmer seines hauses gefunden
neben der leiche sitzt ein verstörter
elfjähriger junge
in der wohnung des allein stehenden
mannes entdeckt die polizei ein komplett
eingerichtetes kinderzimmer
spielzeug schlaf matratzen und auf
seinem computer
kinderpornografische fotos
der 32 jährige arzt starb eines
natürlichen todes er litt an einer
herzkrankheit
als miriam severing die polizeistation
wieder verlässt hat sie erfahren dass
ihr sohn in eine polizeiliche nackte
geführt wird als ein kind das mutmaßlich
von dem verstorbenen arzt sexuell
missbraucht worden ist
beschäftigt war derart damals am
universitätsklinikum des saarlandes in
homburg
das war wie in einem albtraum ich habe
das überhaupt nicht begreifen können was
man dir da gesagt hat mein sohn sexuell
missbraucht und das in der uniklinik des
saarlandes wo man kennt über jahre in
behandlung war
und wenn das stimmt warum habe ich davon
nie etwas erfahren
dass ihr kennt womöglich sexuell
missbraucht wurde ist für die familie
ein albtraum dass sie über jahre darüber
nicht informiert wurden weder von der
klinik noch von der polizei ist für die
mutter unbegreiflich der verstorbene
arzt hat möglicherweise noch viel mehr
kinder missbraucht und in dem
universitätskrankenhaus soll es noch
weitere täter geben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der verstorbene arzt soll nicht nur den
sohn von miriam severing missbraucht
haben sondern auch andere kinder
staatsanwaltschaft klinik und auch das
land wussten von den vorwürfen nur die
eltern der betroffenen kinder wurden
über jahre nicht informiert
zdfzoom will mehr über die hintergründe
dieses skandals erfahren
[Musik]
das universitätsklinikum des saarlandes
ak es besteht aus 30 fachkliniken die
aufsicht über das uksh hat die
landesregierung dort zuständig ist der
ministerpräsident bzw die
ministerpräsidentin
ganz am rande des klinikgeländes
befindet sich die kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie das uke in der
ausscheidungs ambulanz werden kinder
behandelt die unter ein essen und ein
quoten leiden er arbeitete seit dem jahr
2010 matthias es als assistenzarzt
und hier aber auch der sohn von miriam
severing in behandlung
als ich von der polizei kam habe ich
meinen mann angerufen und ihm gesagt
dass wir sofort in die klinik nach
hamburg müssen dann haben wir dort
angerufen und angekündigt dass wir
kommen würden und den klinikchef
sprechen wollen da haben wir noch
gehofft dass das alles ein irrtum ist
vielleicht eine verwechslung und dass es
in der kinderpsychiatrie natürlich
keinen kindesmissbrauch gegeben hat
erst wollten sie uns abwimmeln der chef
der kinderpsychiatrie wäre in urlaub und
nicht erreichbar
ich habe denen gesagt dass wir so lange
bleiben bis wir die patientenakte
unseres kindes haben dass wir vorher
nicht weggehen plötzlich haben sie mir
ein telefon in die hand gedrückt da war
dann der klinikdirektor dran und er
sagte dann das wäre die schwerste
entscheidung seines lebens gewesen also
uns nicht zu informieren und dann hat er
uns noch ein persönliches gespräch
angeboten das gespräch hat aber nie
stattgefunden
es hat sich auch nie mehr jemand von der
klinik bei uns gemeldet
in ihrer not wenden sich die eltern an
claudia willger die rechtsanwältin ist
spezialisiert auf den opferschutz in
missbrauchsfällen ich habe wirklich
schon viele schwierige
lebensgeschichten gehört aber dass da
hat einfach meine vorstellungskraft
absolut gesprengt dass ausgerechnet in
einer kinder- und jugendpsychiatrie
kinder so was von verraten werden ich
konnte es mir nicht vorstellen dass auch
eltern so wenig respekt
gegenüber gebracht wird wenn sie hier
ihre kinder zur behandlung bringen und
was ich mir auch nicht vorstellen konnte
die einstellung der staatsanwaltschaft
die staatsanwaltschaft hatte zwar gegen
den arzt ermittelt aber mit dem tod des
beschuldigten wurden die akten
geschlossen dass kinder in einem
krankenhaus missbraucht wurden sollte
offensichtlich niemand erfahren
auch die staatsanwaltschaft hätte schon
eine ganz andere dynamik in die
ermittlungen rein bekommen wenn sie die
eltern informiert und auch als zeugen
vernommen hätte und dann kommt noch dazu
dass hier eltern in dem moment wo sie
nicht informiert werden ja auch die
rechte ihrer kinder gar nicht wahrnehmen
können sie können für ihre kinder gar
keine entscheidungen treffen und was
noch viel schlimmer ist sie verstehen
ihre eigenen kinder nicht mehr
auch miriam severing war aufgefallen
dass sich ihr sohn manchmal seltsam
verhielt manchmal versteckte er sich
wollte nicht ins krankenhaus immer öfter
wehrte er sich dagegen wenn ein besuch
in der kinderpsychiatrie anstand
uns werden dokumente zugespielt es sind
belege dafür dass matthias s mindestens
34 kinder möglicherweise hunderte
mutmaßlich sexuell missbraucht hat dass
der verstorbene assistenzarzt seine
kleinen patienten übergriffig behandeln
würde dafür gab es schon sehr frühe
anzeichen
wir stoßen auf einen brisanten hinweis
ein anonymes schreiben vom juli 2011 an
den direktor der kinderpsychiatrie in
dem behauptet wird dass ein
assistenzarzt matthias es eine pädophile
veranlagung habe er behandle kinder im
genitalbereich ohne dass es nötig
gewesen wäre
er würde auch bei sich zu hause kleine
jungen behandeln außerdem verschaffte er
sich als jugendtrainer in einem judo
verein zutritt zu kindern und
jugendlichen
auch im ärztlichen kollegium fällt auf
dass der assistenzarzt die kinder
alleine in seinem raum behandelt die
eltern müssen draußen bleiben ihnen
erklärt er dass sich ihre kinder vor
ihnen schämen würden der arzt verwendet
außergewöhnlich viele christ ihre
hilfsmittel mit denen er entsprechend
viele einläufe macht und der direktor
der kinderpsychiatrie
unseren recherchen zufolge berät sich
der direktor der kinderpsychiatrie mit
einer kollegin in zukunft soll der
assistenzarzt kinder nur noch im beisein
einer erwachsenen person behandeln
dürfen aber der assistenzarzt macht
weiter wie bisher
die anweisung wird nicht kontrolliert
darüber wollen wir mit dem damaligen
direktor der kinderpsychiatrie reden
auch darüber warum er die eltern der
kinder nie informierte zu den vorwürfen
äußert er sich nicht
2012 reist assistenzarzt matthias es
nach vietnam auf der urlaubsreise mit
dabei ein ärztlicher kollege aus der
klinik dieser wird zeuge wie es mehrere
jungen in sein hotelzimmer mitnehmen
will darüber geraten sie in einen streit
im saarland aber er fährt niemand davon
im internet finden der scheinbar
harmlose kinderporträts die der
assistenzarzt in vietnam gemacht hat
[Musik]
fotos die sogar in der
universitätsklinik ausgestellt werden
darüber wie sie entstanden sind spricht
keiner auch nicht der kollege der in
vietnam dabei war und auch nicht der
direktor der kinderpsychiatrie
[Musik]
homburg erbach im örtlichen sportzentrum
trainiert assistenzarzt matthias es als
freizeit trainer die bambini die
jüngsten judoka im klub bei dem die
eltern vertrauen übernachtet manche ein
judoka bei ihm zu hause auch der
elfjährige junge den die polizei neben
dem verstorbenen arzt eintraf war ein
bambino aus dem judo club
zuvor schon hatte eine mutter von ihrem
sohn erfahren dass in der freizeit
trainer körperlich belästige sie meldet
das den sportfunktionären auch dem
judoclub in erbach und sie fordert dass
sich der trainer von ihrem sohn
fernhalten soll trotz der warnung fährt
matthias es als betreuer einer
jugendgruppe nach israel hier wird
beobachtet wie einen jungen judoka
abends mit auf sein zimmer nimmt
teilnehmer der reise bezeugen dass die
jugend warten des judo bundes carolin
schmitz doch aus israel telefonisch über
den vorfall informiert wurde
vor dem untersuchungsausschuss behauptet
sie allerdings dass sie von den
vorwürfen erst aus der zeitung erfahren
habe weder der saarländische noch der
deutsche judo-bund haben auf unsere
anfragen reagiert
im april 2014 verlässt der assistenzarzt
die kinderpsychiatrie in hamburg um
seine facharztausbildung in
kaiserslautern zu beenden
wie erfahren sein chef hatte ihm
zugesagt dass er als facharzt jederzeit
zurückkommen könne doch im kollegium der
jugendpsychiatrie regt sich widerstand
gegen seine rückkehr der klinikchef
überprüft stichprobenartig
patientenakten von matthias s und stellt
fest dass in 95 prozent aller fälle die
untersuchungen an den geschlechtsteilen
und die vielen einläufe medizinisch
überhaupt nicht notwendig waren
knapp ein jahr nachdem matthias es die
klinik verlassen hat wird gegen ihn
anzeige erstattet der leiter der kinder-
und jugendpsychiatrie geht zur polizei
er erzählt von den auffälligen
patientenakten nennt zeugen denen
verdächtiges aufgefallen sei seine
größte sorge aber ist dass die eltern
davon erfahren nur wenn die polizei
nicht an die eltern antreten würde er
die daten zur verfügung stellen sagte
der damalige klinikchef in der
polizeilichen vernehmung gegenüber dem
zdf äußert er sich auch dazu nicht
die eltern der betroffenen kinder
bleiben weiter ahnungslos erfahren
nichts von der anzeige und auch nichts
von den ermittlungen gegen den
assistenzarzt jahre vergehen erst durch
einen zufall kommt alles raus als
mehrere severing von der polizei 2009 10
über den mutmaßlichen missbrauch ihres
sohnes informiert wird die
eingeschaltete rechtsanwältin fordert
von der staatskanzlei aufklärung denn
die aufsicht über das
universitätsklinikum liegt beim
wissenschaftsministerium und das hatte
damals die ministerpräsidentin des
saarlandes annegret kramp karrenbauer
inne
wir sichten dokumente aus denen
hervorgeht warum die eltern nie
informiert wurden vereinbarungen
zwischen klinik und staatsanwaltschaft
ebenso verfügungen in den ministerien
der landesregierung
stoßen auf ein kartell des schweigens
[Musik]
ende juni 2009 10 wenige tage zuvor
haben wir die landesregierung mit
unseren recherchen konfrontiert
im justizministerium findet eine eilig
einberufene pressekonferenz statt
ich möchte sie und die öffentlichkeit
über einen verdachtsfall sexuellen
missbrauches zu heilen assistenzarzt und
zu unserem universitätsklinikum
informieren warum aber die eltern
darüber über jahre nie informiert wurden
erfährt man nicht auch nicht wie die
klinikleitung die ermittelnde
staatsanwaltschaft unter druck setzte am
23.6 2016 schreibt die
staatsanwaltschaft bislang wurden die
betroffenen patienten beziehungsweise
deren eltern über das verfahren noch
nicht in kenntnis gesetzt es ist
grundsätzlich beabsichtigt diese lume
über das verfahren zu informieren
einen monat später am 22 07 2011 16
schreibt die universitätsklinik dass das
ausmaß der sexuellen übergriffe für das
einzelne kind verhältnismäßig gering sei
und nach ihrer einschätzung wäre es
sinnvoll die familien überhaupt nicht zu
kontaktieren im dezember schreibt die
staatsanwaltschaft entgegen der
erwägungen ist nicht mehr beabsichtigt
die betroffenen patienten bzw deren
eltern zu informieren unter anderem da
dies die gefahr birgt dass andere
patienten dann von dritten von den
tatvorwürfen erfahren
in einer mitteilung an das
justizministerium schreibt
oberstaatsanwalt görlinger das so
wörtlich eine bisher befürchtete
hysterie welle ausgeblieben sei und
damit das so bleibe sei nicht mehr
beabsichtigt die betreffenden eltern
über das ermittlungsverfahren zu
unterrichten
während der pressekonferenz fragen wir
den oberstaatsanwalt warum er die eltern
nicht informieren wollte
wir meinen dass die kinder die
deren missbrauch im rahmen des
verhandlungsergebnisses ist damals ging
noch nicht verletzte im sinne der
vorschriften gewesen sind weil das noch
nicht eine entsprechende konkret
erreicht hatte dass wir das
verantwortlich hätten sagen können ist
unsinn natürlich ist ein potentiell
betroffenes kind auch weil noch nicht
feststeht was passiert ist ist natürlich
ein verletzter im sinn des gesetzes so
lange bis es endgültig geklärt ist
hartmut wächtler strafrechtler und
richter am bayerischen
verfassungsgerichtshof beurteilt das
verhalten der staatsanwaltschaft als
rechtswidrig es gibt einen paragraphen
406 die in der strafprozessordnung
der regel bis ins einzelne die
informationspflichten der
staatsanwaltschaft und die sind ja
eindeutig nicht erfüllt worden und wenn
die nicht eingehalten werden es ist eine
verletzung des gesetzes und was kann man
einer behörde schlimmeres vorwerfen als
dass sie sich nicht ans gesetz gehalten
hat seit september 2009 10 versucht ein
untersuchungsausschuss den skandal
aufzuklären
auch die damalige ministerpräsidentin
annegret kramp karrenbauer wurde befragt
ihre aussage war dass sie von alledem
nichts gewusst habe dass sie sich aber
gewünscht hätte informiert zu werden
[Musik]
cdu ist die vorsitzende des
parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschusses
heute steht die befragung einer
polizistin auf der tagesordnung die
kommissarin berichtet von ihren
ermittlungsergebnissen im fall des
assistenzarztes
die frage ob sie dafür gewesen sei die
eltern zu informieren
beantwortet sie mit einem klaren ja
der ausschuss versucht die geschehnisse
in der universitätsklinik aufzuklären
aber über die politischen zusammenhänge
erfährt man auch an diesem tag nichts
[Musik]
im saarländischen
justizministerium hatte eine
staatssekretärin ganz im sinne der
klinik und der staatsanwaltschaft
entschieden in einer internen verfügung
heißt es keine informationen der
möglichen opfer von etwaigen straftaten
des assistenzarzt das und sie hatte es
auch unterlassen die damalige
ministerpräsidentin kramp karrenbauer zu
informieren aus gründen des
datenschutzes
rechtfertigt sich die staatssekretärin
gegenüber dem zdf
was sagt die vorsitzende des
untersuchungsausschusses
dazu
zwar in der regierung an einer stelle
bekannt und zwar die sie vor ernannten
die staatssekretärin ja die davon
bescheid wusste von von diesen sachen
ich denke in solchen funktionen
entscheidenden funktionen muss man sich
auch gedanken machen und auch wege
finden um solche sachen vielleicht auch
weiterzugeben nicht vielleicht um solche
sachen dann auch weiterzugeben damit
genau an ihnen gearbeitet werden kann
weil jedes kind was hier betroffen war
ja ist ein kind zu viel gewesen nach
brauche ich auch nicht extra zu
wiederholen stellvertretender
vorsitzender des
untersuchungsausschusses ist dennis
länder für uns wird natürlich die große
frage sein inwieweit politische
einflussnahme letztendlich eine rolle
gespielt hat aber wir wissen ja auf
jeden fall schon dass beispielsweise das
universitätsklinikum sehr sehr darauf
bedacht war dass der eigene ruf keinen
schaden nimmt und dass man mit diesem
ansinnen eben auch an die
staatsanwaltschaft herangegangen ist und
daneben hat die staatsanwaltschaft dem
letztendlich auch gefolgt aber wie
gesagt für uns wird auch die politische
einflussnahme eine sehr große rolle
spielen
während der sitzungspause werden
interviews gegeben
neben den journalisten steht ein mann
der nur zuhört auch sein sohn wurde in
der saarländischen universitätsklinik
mutmaßlich misshandelt allerdings nicht
in der kinderpsychiatrie sondern in
einer anderen klinik der hno hierher
kommen einfach um zu sehen ob es
parallelen von den fällen der knoten
psychiatrie gibt zu den fällen der heino
ob man da eben schlüsse ziehen könnte
einfach vielleicht auch um anderen
betroffenen
ein stück weit helfen zu können
die hals nasen ohren klinik ist eine
weitere fachklinik auf dem gelände des
uke hier soll sein sohn missbraucht
worden sein und auch hier geht es um
vertuschung
im herbst 2014 wurde sein sohn in der
hno klinik operiert während der
ärztlichen morgenbesprechung habe damals
der hno direktor erzählt dass ein
sexueller kindesmissbrauch geschehen sei
zeugen des gesprächs berichten uns wie
der chef seine mitarbeiter verpflichtet
habe darüber zu schweigen
staatsanwaltliche ermittlungen wurden
damals nicht eingeleitet der chef der
hno äußert sich dazu nicht
die kollegen glauben dass es sich um
einen einzelfall handelt der gerade
geschehen sei der herrscher verschweigt
aber dass ein weiterer mutmaßlicher
kindesmissbrauch in der hno bereits seit
2012 aktenkundig ist damals rief ein
arzt aus dem hahn operationssaal die
kinderschutzgruppe des uniklinikums an
er habe nach einer operation im
nasen-rachen-raum bei der verabreichung
eines schmerz zäpfchen es eine blutende
wunde im genitalbereich sowie einen
klaffenden anus festgestellt das
sechsjährige mädchen könnte fraglich
vergewaltigt worden sein so steht es in
einem bericht des arztes
das mädchen das damals in der hno klinik
operiert wurde ist ihre tochter bis
heute hat sie die kranken märkte ihrer
tochter aufbewahrt
immer in der hoffnung dass sich doch
noch aufklären lässt wer dafür
verantwortlich ist was ihrem kind
während des aufenthalts in der hno
angetan wurde
die mutter die wir maria melcher nennen
möchte unerkannt bleiben ihre tochter
weiß bis heute nichts von dem was
während der narkose geschehen ist wann
haben sie denn dann mitbekommen dass
irgendwas passiert sein muss
das war montags da ist der arzt gekommen
von der kinderklinik und der hat mir
dann erzählt dass während der op
aufgefallen ist dass meine tochter einen
blutigen riss hat eine anal frisur hat
und ja wie hat der arzt das erklärt
der arzt hat zuerst gar nichts erklärt
hat gesagt er kümmert sich darum er
möchte wissen was passiert ist
er hat allerdings auch so sachen gefragt
ob ich mir vorstellen kann dass das zu
hause passiert ist er wollte auch wissen
wie lange ich mit meinem freund zusammen
bin und ich habe ihm dann geantwortet
dass das zuhause nicht passiert ist ich
habe meine kinder beide noch vor der op
in die badewanne gesteckt
er hat auch ganz komisch reagiert hat
gemeint ja ihre tochter ist ja schon
sechs jahre alt woher wollen sie wissen
dass beim baden nicht auch schon eine
verletzung war
sind sie dabei wenn ihr kind baden tut
als derart die mutter nach ihren
privaten verhältnissen fragt steht
längst fest dass die wunde nur im
operationssaal entstanden sein konnte
der befund bericht des
rechtsmedizinischen instituts des ubs
bestätigt dass die verletzung als
einwirkung durch äußere gewalt
einzustufen sei
das wunder frische einzustufen
das macht mich verdammt wütend vor allem
im nachhinein ist mir auch bewusst
geworden dass die gerichtsmedizinerin
schon aufgeschrieben hatte dass die
wunde frisch ist erst ein paar minuten
alt das heißt wie ich meine tochter
morgens in die klinik gebracht hatte war
alles okay und trotzdem hinterher noch
irgendwie zu versuchen den schwarzen
peter mir zuzuschieben ist unmöglich
einfach unverschämt
[Musik]
stefanie und dominic koß war sind
ebenfalls nicht gut auf die hno-klinik
zu sprechen ihr sohn wurde ebenfalls in
der klinik mutmaßlich missbrauchten
wurde
aufgenommen um in der hi lo pariert zu
werden ich habe ihn dann am tag der
operation an der schleuse abgegeben und
musste dann warten bis er wieder im
aufwachraum ist ich hab dann gewartet
also es kam mir etwa einer stunde vor
und dann konnte ich wieder rein zu ihm
dann habe ich die windel aufgemacht und
habe dann eben diese verletzung im after
bereich entdeckt die geblutet hat dann
hat eine weile gedauert dann kamen eine
schwester und ihr dann gesagt ich soll
mich nicht so aufregen dass wir alles
gar nicht so schlimm ist ein bisschen
creme drauf machen und dann ging das
schon wieder ich saß dann quasi am bett
von von meinem sohn und
war total fertig und es hat ihn einfach
keiner mehr nach uns geguckt um ein paar
tage später wurde ein 1 1 gespräch
veranlasst da war der klinikdirektor von
der kinderklinik unter kinder der
direktor von der hals nasen ohren klinik
mit den beiden habe ich das gespräch
gehabt und es ist mir erklärt worden
dass nichts schlimmes passiert sei in
den op bereich oder es wurde gesagt es
war ein zäpfchen dass unsachgemäß
gegeben wurde quasi in der verpackung
versucht wurden zu geben es kam mir vor
wie ein schlechter witz weil jeder der
kinder hat kann seinem kind ein zäpfchen
geben ohne dass irgendwelche
verletzungen entstehen und vor allen
dingen das ist ja geschultes personal in
der klinik das sind ausgebildete
schwestern auf die idee glaube ich kommt
kein mensch so einen tag später am
entlastung sind wir dann wie uns
empfohlen wurde zu einer unabhängigen
krankenhaus hier in der region gegangen
die haben diese verletzung am after
bereich dokumentiert und hat die blauen
flecke
dokumentiert und hat in den bericht rein
geschrieben
das aussieht wie eine pak hand so dass
man quasi die finger einer hand auf dem
oberkörper unseres sohnes sehen konnte
man geht mit seiner geschichte an die
polizei und man hofft einfach dass es
aufgeklärt wird und es passiert nichts
wir wissen nicht was mit unserem kind
passiert ist wir wissen es immer noch
nicht und wir werden es auch
wahrscheinlich dann gar nicht mehr
erfahren man würde gerne
schreien
[Musik]
die eltern erzählen uns dass die
klinikleitung ihnen ein angebot gemacht
habe eine entschädigung von 5000 euro zu
zahlen das angebot haben die eltern
abgelehnt
tatsächlich habe die staatsanwaltschaft
die ermittlungen eingestellt weil kein
täter zu ermitteln sei damit bleiben die
verdachtsfälle in der hno-klinik
ungeklärt auch damit hat sich der
untersuchungsausschuss beschäftigt bis
jetzt ohne ergebnis
es ist eine niederlage für den
kinderschutz und es ist ein riesenmarkt
für die hno das nicht aufgeklärt werden
kann wie es sein kann dass zwischen
abgabe eines kindes in den op und am
ende wieder herauskommen einer
verletzung stattfinden kann dass das
nicht aufgeklärt werden kann schon aus
der institution selbst heraus das ist
unfassbar
und das ist überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehbar wenn eltern mich heute
fragen ob sie ihre kinder guten
gewissens dieser hano übereignen können
dann würde ich eindeutig sagen nein
damit aber nicht genug
seit jahren schwelt in der hals nasen
ohrenklinik noch ein weiterer konflikt
mitarbeiterinnen beschweren sich über
das übergriffige verhalten ihres
direktors
im dezember 2017 schickt die anti
diskriminierungs behörde des bundes
einen bericht an das klinikum über einen
eklatanten fall von sexuellen
belästigungen am arbeitsplatz die
sexuellen belästigungen des
klinikdirektors würden seit jahren
anhalten und stetig in ihrer intensität
anwachsen eine mitarbeiterin habe er an
die bekleideten brüste gefasst ein
anderes mal dicht an sie geschickt wobei
sie das geschlechtsteil des arztes
gespürt habe nach zeitweiliger
suspendierung ist er wieder im amt damit
er das handwerk des operateurs nicht
verlernt heißt es in der begründung der
staatskanzlei die ermittlungen gegen ihn
dauern noch an professor es bestreitet
die vorwürfe
der untersuchungsausschuss hat jetzt
seine beweisaufnahme beendet jetzt wird
am abschlussbericht gearbeitet die
eltern der betroffenen kinder wollen
dass die schuldigen zur verantwortung
gezogen werden doch sie haben wenig
hoffnung dass die hintergründe der
mutmaßlichen missbrauchsfälle wirklich
aufgeklärt werden
der direktor des gesamt klinikums
berichtet von einem neuen schutzkonzept
dass solche fälle in zukunft verhindern
soll er beurteilt das schweigen
gegenüber den eltern anders als seine
vorgänger
hätte von anfang an und das stehe ich
auch dafür das war bisher meine absicht
so und es ist auch so dass man maximale
aufarbeitung und transparenz haben muss
das heißt im endeffekt man hätte damals
die eltern die kinder schon informieren
müssen eigentlich was dann vorgefallen
ist einen tag vor diesem interview
erfahren wir dass es noch einen fall
sexueller belästigung in der
universitätsklinik gegeben hat ein arzt
in der onkologie sei fristlos entlassen
worden wir haben letzte woche erstmals
davon dass mitbekommen dass dieser
kollege angezeigt worden ist es liegt
eine anzeige vor von einer ehemaligen
patientin das ganze liegt auch wieder um
jahre zurück 20 18 er hätte sie damals
sexuell belästigt gerührt und jetzt sind
im rahmen von diesen ermittlungen
untersuchungen ist festgestellt worden
dass er wohl anscheinend
pornografisches kinderpornografisches
material auf sein
hat aber ich glaube das sind noch
ermittlungen die noch am laufen sind und
deswegen will ich auch da den gar nicht
vorgreifen und auch dazu auf keinem
wehtun stellungen
über die homepage des krankenhauses
können missbrauchsfälle jetzt online
angezeigt werden lange zeit war die
seite leider nicht abrufbar bedauert der
klinikdirektor jetzt aber würde das
schutzkonzept funktionieren
konzepte ratgeber und kampagnen zum
schutz von kindern auch gerade in
kliniken gibt es bundesweit doch wenn
der missbrauch wie im saarland auf ein
kartell des schweigens trifft haben es
die täter leicht das leid der opfer
bleibt hier sind die verantwortlichen
weiter gefordert das ist man den
betroffenen kindern und eltern schuldig